bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be on to you I'm Eddie your host
of the Deen show that's why you're
watching a Deen show every week same
time same Channel and in the studio
we're gonna talking to American former
Christian Christian scholar dr. Gerald
Dirk's and we're gonna be talking about
the Muslim identity when we come back
here on the D show
hey what's up how you doing please be
here always peace be it please be with
you I just wanted to start you for a
second I was like hey how you doing but
how we do it is with the peace we give
the peace yes because we want peace
absolutely definitely and peace not just
between you and me but peace between and
among all people absolutely you know
islam teaches that we are all brothers
in humanity that all brothers and
sisters yes and we share because we care
absolutely that's why we're doing the
Deen show to enlighten the minds and the
hearts of the people and today we're
gonna be talking about the identity you
are an American and you're Muslim yes
does this conflict at all no not at all
but unfortunately a lot of people think
it does conflict and real unfortunately
even a lot of Muslims think that it
needs to conflict and this brings up an
issue that I think is vitally important
to Muslims here in America and that is
the issue of the second and third
generation of Muslims in America and
issues surrounding their development of
a sense of identity mm-hmm I was born
here raised in America and I personally
had some experiences when I started to
you know come to this way the way of the
Creator Islam submitting to the one God
people would ask because you know my
name is Eddie sure so people would say
like well when you're gonna get AMISOM
name you know and so you would you know
you want to do God's thing but sometimes
you know the culture will creep in and
you feel like am i doing god's thing or
I'm doing back home culture exactly
exactly
you know you said when are you gonna get
a Muslim name I've had the same question
asking me but in reality there's no such
thing as a Muslim name there's Arab
names uh-huh you know there are names
associated with with Prophet Muhammad
and his companions etc but to limit
these to being Muslim names is rather
ridiculous and there's no reason that
any person
should feel constrained to change his
name unless his name has some clearly
anti-islamic meaning like if it's named
after a pagan god or something yeah okay
yeah now also the dress some people feel
like okay now you know I'm used to maybe
going to work in a in a three-piece suit
or you know modest clothing sure but now
I'll hold on you you you got to throw
this stove on before you go to work now
you're Muslim we did you have to do that
absolutely not yeah no absolutely not if
slot prescribes a modest dress for both
males and females yeah
you know within Western clothing one can
usually find modest dress one doesn't
need to wear a thong or a CUFI on top of
the head etc but one does need to dress
modestly yeah one does not need to eat
kofta kebabs or Brioni but one does have
to follow you know Islamic dietary rules
which is basically no pork no alcohol
and there are a few other meats that are
we were prohibited from eating give us
some more examples of some of the
dilemmas the challenges that you feel
some of the new converts and also just
you know Muslims who come from overseas
and they raise their kids here now
they're having a conflict here with
culture and Muslim and they end up
abandoning everything well for new
converts one of the big issues is do I
have to give up my American identity and
the answer is absolutely not
unfortunately some new converts think
they have to end up becoming more Arab
than an Arab or more Pakistani than a
Pakistani etc and end up really
alienating themselves from their
environment and for many of these people
eventually they end up dropping out of
this law simply because of this
overreaction in the first place you know
that they were actually jumping into a
culture and not to the actual religion
of Islam in terms of the second and
third generation of Muslims in America
this is vitally important because we
have many wonderful immigrant brothers
and sisters who come to this country
they have their children here
raise their children here but
unfortunately many of them I think
they're raising Jordanian children or
Syrian children or Pakistani children or
Bangladeshi children or Indonesian
children and they are not and this is
what is so vitally important that they
need to understand if their children are
being raised here in America they're
raising American children and this is
going to be the national cultural
identity of the vast majority of second
third generation Muslims here in America
their national cultural identity is
being American now really unfortunately
what sometimes happens is that these
Muslim parents who through the best of
intentions fortunately throw up their
hands and alarm and say oh my goodness
you know my son or my daughter is
turning into an American instead of a
Jordanian or a Syrian or or what have
you and I have to stop this I have to
correct this and one of the ways they
tried to do this sometimes is by so
intricately linking Islam with this
foreign culture from back home that when
the kids end up rejecting the foreign
culture in favor of having an American
secular American national cultural
identity they also end up rejecting
Islam as as part of their religious
identity and this is a real danger that
the Muslim parents who are immigrants
need to be aware of your children are
going to be Americans don't fight it
they can be perfectly good Americans and
perfectly good Muslims at the same time
so should the parents be more in tune
with adamantly teaching their children
Islam from the authentic sources the
crown and the Sunnah rather than many of
the back home cultures absolutely and
but but again this is one of the
problems is that for many of our
immigrant brothers and sisters their
culture is so intertwined in their
understanding of Islam
though they may have difficulty doing
that and one of the things that needs to
be done that they need to do and that we
need to be doing in our mosques and in
our private Islamic schools is we need
to make this process of separating
culture from Islam as very important you
know absolutely need to be teaching the
pure Islam we don't need to be teaching
culture definitely and with that said
we'll be right back with more dr. Joe
Dirk's here on the Deen show and if
we're gonna worship something I figured
I might as well worship the Creator
instead of any of the creations now in
upon investigating the religions I
remember find another meaning of what
Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender their self to cut is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will that is Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God your Creator
back here on the Dean show with dr.
Gerald Dirk's moving along now dr.
Gerald please do you see now because of
this pushing the culture on the children
and mixing it so much with Islam and its
confusion that this creates more
confusion and one of the ramifications
is because now because of this the kids
will start to develop a dual personality
well I wouldn't say a dual personality
because that has a definite
psychological implications yes in terms
of a diagnosis but what we do see
happening and brother yaha Emmerich has
written beautifully about this in an
article that every Muslim parent should
read called just what are you thinking
anyway okay which has appeared a couple
of times and the message international
and brother yahia points out and I have
seen this same thing from teaching in
private Islamic schools the kids act one
way at home yeah you know where they
pretend to be Jordanian Indian whatever
but as soon as they're removed from the
home from their parents supervision for
the first time they feel like they can
really be themselves mm-hmm you know
that they're putting on an act at home
they feel they can't be honest and open
with their parents because of all this
cultural pressure that's coming down on
them from their parents and that the
only time they feel there they're truly
free and truly free to be who they are
is when they're away from their parents
away from other adult members of the
Muslim community this is very
troublesome yeah very troublesome you
know speaking from experience the last
private Islamic School in which I taught
I taught English language and social
studies yes I did not teach Islamic
studies
did not teach Quran but the kids the
middle school kids when everything he
would have a question about Islam they
would come to me yes they would not go
to their Islamic studies teacher mm-hmm
wouldn't begin to go to their Islamic
studies teacher to ask the question they
would come to me why I was the American
I was not the person who was going to
stuff down some cultural trappings on
them
yeah so let's separate Islam let's get
to the purest look here Islam yeah as
taught by the last final messengers
after man kind of problem having peace
be upon him absolutely
and obviously it was taught by all the
messengers but we have it now and it's
completion with the last and final
messenger yeah and we have to strip it
from from these cultural accretions that
have occurred across many different
cultures we have to strip it of to be
blunt some of the fairy tales yes that
yet tacked on to Islam by otherwise
well-meaning Muslims yeah I can think of
one example where in and when I was
teaching at the last Islamic school I
was teaching at where the students came
in middle school students came in and
said you know we just learned in Islamic
studies class that if you draw a five
pointed star on the floor and a circle
around it which of course is the
pentagram yeah and you stand in the
middle of it if you try to come out the
jinn will come and immediately kill you
just like that so this is obviously this
was being taught in Islamic studies
class and I said not one no way yeah oh
yes you know our Islamic studies
teachers taught us so I went up to the
blackboard I took a piece of chalk I
went to the back of the room
I drew a five pointed star on the floor
big circle around it and I stepped into
the middle of it and the kids were oh
they're already programmed now you oh
yeah punching the chairs oh yeah and
then I stepped out of course I'm a bit
of a hand
yes and so when I stepped out I clutched
my chest and stumbled two kids screamed
I think they thought I'd just been
killed
yeah now here's the point this myth this
fairy tale was dismantled by a Muslim in
an Islamic setting Wow okay which is
good but what happens if that had never
happened and six years down the road
they're telling their non-muslim friend
about this and the non Muslim friend
does what I did
they've just disproven Islam yes this is
the tremendous danger that exists with
with adding stuff fairy tales cultural
stories etc to the pure message of Islam
get that out we don't need it we don't
need it and and trying to tack it on is
going to lead the next generation to
reject those sorts of things and if it's
tied too tightly to Islam to reject
Islam as well and that's the big big
danger you think this also leads a bad
taste in people's mouths some of the
non-muslims when they see some of these
things this kind of draws them back sets
them back of course it does immediate
gets a hold of some of these things sure
because because I mean what what you're
doing is you're creating differences
differences the don't mean to be there
yeah so if it's so deeply embedded how
does someone where do they begin to fix
this how well I hummed a little I praise
God I think we have to be aware of the
fact that this exists and I think each
and every immigrant Muslim parent in
this country needs to sit down and
discuss this with each other they need
to acknowledge the fact that their kids
if their kids are going to be raised
here are going to be Americans and the
more the parents try to fight this
process the more likely it is they're
going to force their kids away from the
slob hmm you know so fine let your kids
develop an American national cultural
identity they're going to do it anyway
just work on making sure they keep the
Islamic religious identity
but it's the religious identity it's not
the cultural stuff that has been
attached to it so the parents are going
to need to try and separate out what's
religion and what's culture certainly
this is something that we need to be
doing in our mosques definitely
something we need to be doing in our
private Islamic schools we need to be
separating the religion of Islam from
whatever culture we happen to come from
now that doesn't mean that you're an
American now that you as a Muslim now
we're talking about hey you know I can
go and have a six-pack of beer or I'm
going to the nightclubs I'm living a
freestyle lifestyle as they call it
no no we take the good from the culture
but we hold our identity as once we have
submitted the card and we do all the
good wholesome things and we stay away
from to all the evil elements look you
know going out and getting drunk or
using drugs is not part of the American
identity yeah it's a part of the
identity a subgroup of people but
certainly not just people in America
because some people say All American oh
you're American now so you can just let
loose no no that's not effective if we
look certainly there are a lot of
Christian groups that share the same
social values that we share yeah you
know where they're against drinking
they're against drugs they're against
premarital sex etc you know so hey if
they can be Americans and maintain their
religious values we can be Americans and
maintain our Islamic values but we need
to make sure that what we're talking
about is what the religion actually says
with the Quran and the Sunna actually
tell us to do absolutely and we'll be
right back with more here on the Disha
okay you've got your dream home and
you've got your dream car but you're
gonna get old and things are going to
happen to you in your life and then what
have you got at the end of the day is an
empty dream that has no real foundation
we are gonna die and we're gonna meet
our Lord and he is gonna judge us it
becomes an obligation for each single
human being to find out what the Quran
is Islam is telling us to stay away from
things which are bad for your person and
bad for the society
back here on the Dean show with dr.
Gerald Dirk's we're talking about the
Muslim identity identity and a Muslim is
one who is consciously chosen to submit
to the one God doing God's will not our
desires and we're talking about leaving
off some of the back home cultures which
you'll actually see a lot of times God
Almighty says to be united not divided
and do you see a lot of times this
divides the community of course it
divides the community because America
where we're looking at a melting pot
we're looking at Muslims who have come
from Indonesia from Malaysia from India
Bangladesh from Pakistan from each of
the Arab countries from many of the
African countries for looking at
african-americans who have reached back
to their ancestral past to claim Islam
as their religion so then we have all
these different cultures here but the
next generation that second generation
you know they're the ones being raised
in this culture they're going to be
Americans etc one of the the real
challenges that the Muslim community has
in America is this whole issue of
tribalism or nationalism yeah
ethnocentrism however you want to call
it nationalism just holding on to just
you know yeah the flag and yeah
absolutely absolutely just because a
flag they're holding on to it's not the
American flag yeah you know a survey was
done by sponsored by care yeah a number
of years ago called a portrait of a
mosque in America I think was the name
of the big survey yeah and one of the
things they discovered in their national
survey of mosques around the country is
that 27% 27% of the mosques in this
country reported that they were one of
their key goals was to preserve a
certain ethnic or national heritage
now I'm sorry brother I don't think
there's any way that that's a proper
goal of a mosque what that's saying is
that 27 percent of the mosques in
America are systematically excluding
every Muslim who does not happen to
belong to that particular ethnic or
national grouping US should be open to
every muscle everybody everybody we're
all brothers we are all brothers and
sisters and we shouldn't be divided like
this absolutely we shouldn't be divided
yeah and yet we see the the Muslim
community being divided so often along
tribal lines or ethnic lines etc and it
weakens us and fatally weakens us as a
religious community if you go to a large
American city and you stop a Muslim on
the street and you say where's the
mosque you're likely to get an answer to
go something like this well you know the
arab mosque is over here the indo-pak
mosque is over here and over here
there's an african-american must drop
all that oh we have to drop off yeah we
have to become one Muslim family hold on
to the Rope of God hold on to the Rope
of Allah this is what the crater is
telling us isn't he oh absolutely yeah
so now we're almost out of time continue
to give us some advice this is a very
very very very important topic and we
want to be united we don't want to be
divided because the key divider is the
Shaitaan the Satanic forces Allah wants
us to be together
functioning as one unit worshiping one
guy absolutely so give us a few closing
comments and suggestions for the
community at large well let me speak
directly to the immigrant Muslims who
are parents here in this country you
know it's inevitable your children
especially your grandchildren they're
gonna start losing your native language
they're gonna start losing some of your
native recipes as far as cooking in etc
this is to be expected the more you
fight it the more conflict you're likely
to have with your children and I say
this morning I had as a child clinical
psychologist
accept the fact that your children are
going to be Americans that your
grandchildren are going to become
Americans don't get distracted by
whether they're wearing a sarong or a
sari or whether they're wearing modest
western clothes focus on the pure
teachings of Islam make sure that's in
place don't waste your time and your
energy and your influence trying to
build in cultural issues and to your
children mm-hmm now the good things from
culture let's say you mentioned but
irani if they want to still eat biryani
and some of the good thing I don't have
this fun I have to give up all that
right no they don't have to give it up
that's fine if they want to do it
yeah you know I'm a german-american
background yeah you know I still enjoy
eating sauerbraten yeah supposed to be
back yeah
yeah if I switch the racket but don't
make that part of the don't make that
the religion no don't make that the
religion don't force it on your children
there's no grandchildren got you you
know if they want to grab it they'll
grab it don't force it on got you okay
and people get a hold of you if they
want to invite you to come visit we're
at they can reach me at my website thank
you very much me god almighty allah the
creator of the heavens and ever reward
you once again oh thank you brother
thank you and you got to hear some great
advice from dr. Gerald Dirk's born bred
and raised American he's telling us as a
law is telling you to hold on to the
Rope of God of the Creator Allah and be
not divided amongst yourselves we need
to be one one humanity worshipping the
one God and if you got some back home
culture you'd like that food the biryani
go ahead and eat that some people can't
it's too hot and too spicy but that's
not wrong with it what we're saying is
don't mix your back whole cultures with
Islam don't mix it Islam is pure it's
from the creator of the heavens and
earth and we have the verbatim Word of
God the Koran and we have the Sunnah the
authentic teachings from the last and
final messenger sent to mankind
no more messengers to come get to know
this and teach this and live this and
that is how we can attain
peace and that's how we can stay united
and we'll see you next time here on the
Dean show until then peace be unto you